[Musique]
vous souvenez cette déclaration du
président américain le 10 février
dernier qui affirmait que le printemps
et la chaleur printanière allait tout
simplement tuer le virus mais les faits
et la réalité prouve le contraire
et pour cette croyance émane en grande
partie du fait que la prévalence de la
grippe saisonnière
l'influenza ben coïncide avec les
températures plus froides et l'
isolement qui en découlent mais
attention pour pas faire ce genre de
parallèle selon bon nombre d'experts à
ce stade-ci rien qu'ils prouvent dirais
que température chaude et l'air ambiant
fit en sorte que le virus est
généralement moins stable dans
l'environnement
mais ça veut pas dire pour autant que
les risques de transmission sont
éliminés la transmission par contact va
peut-être est un peu moins efficace mais
la transmission par gouttelettes elle
continue de fonctionner à preuve il est
important de noter que le corps à des
virus à l'origine de la comédie 19
s'adapte plutôt bien aux pays tropicaux
ou subtropicaux au moment d'enregistrer
cette capsule on constate qu'à huit pays
d'asie du sud est où ce type de corps
anna virus est présent il ya une
trentaine de nations africaines où c'est
la même chose et environ 25 pays
d'amérique latine et des caraïbes où le
coroner virus à l'origine de la coved de
19 et bien présent donc même si les
connaissances scientifiques sur ce
nouveau type de caranavi russes sont
très embryonnaire il faut pas penser que
la chaleur fait en sorte que les risques
de contagion s'estompe pour une raison
bien simple parmi tant d'autres si on se
met dans cet état d'esprit la baisse la
garde ont réduit les mesures de sécurité
et vous connaissez la suite
en somme pendant que les scientifiques
partout dans le monde sont en train de
se familiariser à la vitesse grand v
avec ce nouveau type de virus
restons patients
et restons surtout très prudent pour
plus de détails sur la question de la
chaleur et de ses effets a légué sur le
nouveau type de corne au virus
j'invite à lire mon article que j'ai
écrit à ce sujet on le trouve sur la
page web des décrypteurs est également
continuer à nous écrire à notre courriel
ou sur notre groupe facebook
allez salut